PROFESSOR: This brings me to
my third example of divination
in the early Christian period.
And this example is an actual
Christian divination book
that we have here at Harvard.
It dates likely from the
Fifth or the Sixth Century.
This book is very, very tiny.
It measures less than three
inches in height and in width.
It could have fit in the
palm of someone's hand.
It's made of vellum.
It's been tested, and it
was sheepskin that was used.
And the writing on it is a very
fine uncials, a fine handwriting
that kind of imitates the
handwriting that would
have been used for a biblical text.
It's a text that in
its very paleography,
in the very script that it uses,
claims a kind of authority for itself.
A sophisticated style of writing.
The text is titled The
Gospel of the Lots of Mary.
And within it, it
contains multiple oracles.
And we're not really sure how it would
have been used, to tell you the truth.
What's clear is that someone
held it in their hand.
And if you look closely at the text,
you can see that it's been well-thumbed.
The middle of each page is dark
with the stains of sweat and dirt
from a ritual expert who
would have held it and thumbed
through the pages trying to find an
answer to the petitioner's questions.
We can imagine the possibility that
a petitioner in the Fifth Century
or in the Sixth Century in Egypt--
because the text is written in
Coptic, the common language in Egypt
at that time--
that the petitioner would have
come to the ritual expert, who
would have held a text like
this in his or her hands
and leafed through it to find an
answer to the petitioner's troubles.
It's a practice not unlike
that we found at Cremna,
although at Cremna it
was a public practice
in a public square of
throwing the astragalus
and trying to find an
answer from the god.
In this case, we have a practice with a
small book, a kind of bibliomancy where
a given page would tell you
the answer to the question
that you held in your heart and that
you discussed with the ritual expert
about your future.
Let me read you the
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],
or the introduction, of the text,
so that you can have a sense
of the concerns that an early Christian
might have brought to a ritual expert.
"The Gospel of the Lots of Mary,
the mother of the Lord Jesus Christ,
she to whom Gabriel the arch
angel brought the good news.
He will go forward with his whole
heart, will obtain what he seeks.
Only do not be of two minds."
The handwriting that looks
like a biblical script.
The reference to Mary, the
mother of Jesus Christ.
These give a kind of
authority to the text,
a kind of religious sanction to it.
The first Oracle reads this way.
"Oh, human.
With their tongues
they love you greatly,
but their heart is far from you.
And you know what happened to you before
today that you almost lost your life.
In any case, they certainly
lie in wait for you."
The oracles in this small
little divination device
often talk about not fearing,
about trusting in God.
They give pieces of divine
advice for the Fifth
or the Sixth Century
Egyptian Christian who
came to the ritual expert seeking
some understanding of what
might happen in his or her
future, seeking some guidance
in his or her path for the present.